dear vice Chancellor of the
Confederation ladies and gentlemen the
federal Council had an extraordinary
meeting today to discuss the situation
of Credit Suisse this is the fourth
session held by the government in four
days three of those days where dedicated
exclusively to this topic the situation
is well known Credit Suisse is one of
the 30 systemic Global Banks is one of
the two major banks in the country and
its Destiny therefore is not only
decisive for Switzerland our businesses
it's private customers and its employees
but also essential for the stability of
the whole financial sector the Credit
Suisse situation has been a source of
concern for a few months and this is why
the federal Council has had discussions
on several locations on this
in recent days a number of financial
markets have been rocked by the
situation a number of fragile banks have
been
made more fragile and despite as good uh
strong situation because has lost
trust Confidence from the market
the liquidity uh situation of a bank is
one of the Power Ranges
the federal Council has made decisions
on Thursday evening already which came
into effect at 8 pm on Thursday in order
to complement a cash abroad by the BNS
with a second trance of 50 billion
francs that cash flow is made available
as early as Friday the second decision
was already made always also made on
Thursday evening a guarantee of
additional cash to the tune of a hundred
billion of francs
this will be guaranteed by the
Confederation as you can well imagine
that was also one of the discussion
points with the financial delegation
from the parliament today the federal
council is also worked on various
scenarios about Cadiz Swiss which had
already been discussed earlier this year
by the federal Council on Friday we
noticed that cash exits and Market
behavior meant that the trust could not
be restored and that's a very Swift
decision was necessary to guarantee
stability the solution is attitude
tonight it's to take to take over by
candy Swiss by UBS the Confederation is
board the council it supports this
decision after meeting with the Nazis
the finma the regulator Credit Suisse
and UBS
the federal Council
welcomes this it guarantees the
framework conditions essential to its
success